KASLIN FIELDS:
Today, we're going
to explore what it's like
to create your first Google
Kubernetes Engine cluster.
In our GKE Essentials
Cluster Modes video,
we went over the differences
between GKE standard mode
and GKE Autopilot mode clusters.
Now we'll put that
knowledge into action
by creating one of each.
I'm Kaslin Fields,
and I'm a developer
advocate here at
Google Cloud, where
I focus on Google
Kubernetes Engine, as well
as the open-source
Kubernetes project.
So today, we're going to
explore creating your first GKE
cluster.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're going to
deploy our clusters
today using the
Google Cloud Console.
There are many ways to deploy
and manage your clusters,
but the Console is a great
place to start if you
want to learn what's possible.
From here, we're going
to go to the navigation
menu on the upper left
and find Kubernetes
Engine in the Compute section.
You could also
use the search bar
at the top and search for
Kubernetes or Google Kubernetes
Engine.
Now we're in the GKE
section of the Console.
Since Autopilot mode is
still relatively new,
you can see some
information here
about what Autopilot mode
is, along with an option
to try a demo, where you
will create an Autopilot mode
cluster and deploy
a workload into it.
Below that, you'll see
any existing GKE clusters,
along with information
about them,
such as their Name, Location,
Mode, and Resources.
Let's try to create a cluster
by clicking on the Create button
at the top of this page.
The Console prompts us
by asking whether we
would like to create a Standard
mode cluster or an Autopilot
mode cluster, as
well as providing
a link to additional information
about the differences.
So let's start by creating
an Autopilot mode cluster.
On this page, there's
some information
about what creating an Autopilot
mode cluster will give you,
and there are some
input fields where
we will need to specify
information about our cluster.
First, we can specify a Name.
Then, what Region we would
like to run this cluster in.
Remember, all Autopilot mode GKE
clusters are regional clusters,
meaning they're deployed
across the zones that
make up a region, so there's
no need to specify a zone here.
You could simply hit Create
at the bottom of the page
to create the cluster
at this point,
but let's take a look at
the additional options
that you may wish to configure.
If we scroll down, we can
see some expandable sections
for Networking and
Advanced Options.
In Networking, if you choose
to create a public cluster,
then your nodes
will be provisioned
with externally
accessible IP addresses
so that you could reach
the nodes from anywhere
over the internet.
You can also enable control
plane authorized networks
in order to block
untrusted, non-GCP source
IPs from accessing
the Kubernetes
master through HTTPS.
A private cluster will be
one where the nodes are only
accessible via private IPs
on Google Cloud's network.
The nodes of a
private cluster only
communicate via the private
Google Cloud network.
You can configure Cloud Network
Address Translation, or Cloud
NAT, for your nodes
in order for them
to send outbound
requests to the internet.
In Advanced options,
if we scroll down here,
you can see
configuration options
for the Release channel
for your GKE cluster.
When you enroll a new
cluster in a release channel,
Google automatically manages
the version and upgrade cadence
for that cluster
and its node pools.
Your choice of release channel
between Rapid, and Regular,
and Stable will
affect how quickly
new versions of
Kubernetes become
available for your
cluster to upgrade
and how often your
cluster must upgrade
to stay in compliance with the
currently supported versions
of Kubernetes.
So for this cluster,
I'm just going
to go with the default,
which is the Regular channel.
If you'll need to specify
acceptable maintenance windows
for your GKE cluster, you
can select Enable maintenance
window here.
You must allow at least 48 hours
of maintenance availability
in a 32-day rolling window,
and a maintenance window
must allot at least four hours
in order to be considered.
These options help you
provide optimal availability
of your cluster,
while allowing Google
to ensure that your clusters
are kept up-to-date with
supported Kubernetes
patches and upgrades.
You can also specify
Metadata and Labels
in order to keep your
cluster resources organized.
The Description
field here can be
used to provide a description
for this cluster's purpose
or any other information you
wish to use to describe it.
For example, I
could put in GKEE--
GKE Essentials-- cluster.
Labels can be used to
help organize resources
within your project.
For example, you
could use labels,
such as prod, dev,
or test, to indicate
the use of different clusters.
Or you could specify a
team name to indicate
that this cluster is intended
for use by that team.
There are many
ways that you could
use labels and metadata to keep
your Cloud resources organized.
Now at the bottom
of this page, we
can use the Create button to
create the cluster that we've
configured, or Cancel to exit
the page without creating
the cluster.
You can also use the REST
or Command Line options here
to get the REST API
call or command for use
with the gcloud CLI in order
to create this cluster using
the CLI or other automation.
So let's create this cluster now
using the Create button here.
So you'll see that our
cluster is now creating.
Its status is this
currently being
created rolling circle here.
You'll also notice here
at the upper right,
you have a notification
icon, where
the circle is going, as well.
When our Autopilot mode GKE
cluster has finished creating,
we'll receive a notification
on this notification icon,
indicating that the
cluster is ready.
Now let's go back
to Create, where
we will explore configuring
a standard mode GKE cluster.
You can see that the format
of the page for creating
a standard mode cluster is
already a little bit different.
The sections you'll
need to go through
to configure your GKE
standard mode cluster
are displayed on the
left-hand side here.
The center contains
the input fields,
where you'll specify your
configuration information.
And the right-hand
side gives a summary
of the cluster you'll
create, including any Cluster
set-up guides used, Immutable
properties that you won't
be able to change once the
cluster is created, billing
information about the
cluster that you're
going to be creating and its
resources, any Beta properties
that you'll be using,
the Limitations
on the size of the cluster,
as well as information
about the Node pools and
the actual instances that
will make up your cluster.
So our first tasks,
again, are to select
a Name for the cluster
and a Zone or a Region.
While Autopilot mode clusters
can only be regional,
standard mode
clusters may also be
configured to run in only a
single zone within a region.
So you can learn more
about the differences
between zonal and regional
clusters in our documentation.
For this cluster, I'll just
make it a Zonal cluster
with the default here.
Again, you'll need to choose
a Release channel to determine
the frequency of Kubernetes
patches and upgrades.
However, in standard
mode, you may also
choose to create a GKE
control plane using
a Static version of Kubernetes.
Using a static version will
require taking responsibility
for managing your
cluster's version
and ensuring the cluster is
using a supported version
of Kubernetes.
Now we could stop here
and create our cluster,
but let's quickly review
the additional configuration
options for a standard
mode GKE cluster.
In the Node Pools
section over here,
you can configure the
number of worker nodes
for your GKE cluster.
You can enable
autoscaling, as well as
node auto-upgrade
and node auto-repair.
You can also select the Number
of nodes for your default node
pool.
In the Nodes section within
the default node pool,
we can see more information
about the nodes themselves,
such as choosing the machine
type, as well as the image--
the operating system that will
be configured on those nodes.
In Security, you can
configure Service accounts,
Cloud API Access scopes,
and Shielded node options.
In the Metadata
section here, you
can add labels specifically
for the nodes of your cluster,
rather than labels
that will be applied
to the cluster as a whole.
You can also specify
Kubernetes Node taints
at this stage to help you
manage what workloads will be
able to run on this node pool.
Within the Cluster
section, you can
configure cluster-level
settings pertaining
to Automation,
Networking, Security,
Metadata, and additional
cluster Features.
So in the Automation
section is where
you can configure
maintenance windows, as we
did in Autopilot mode, as well.
In the Cluster
Networking section,
you can configure public
or private clusters,
as we saw in Autopilot mode.
However, standard
mode also includes
some additional advanced
networking options,
so you might want to
take a look at those.
And in security, you can enable
shielded or Confidential nodes,
secret encryption,
Workload identity,
Google Groups for RBAC, and some
Legacy security options here.
In Metadata, you can configure
cluster-level Description data
and Labels, as we saw
with Autopilot mode.
And in Features,
you can configure
additional Google
Cloud features,
such as Cloud Run for
Anthos, Enabling Cloud
Logging and Monitoring, and
additional capabilities,
such as Cloud TPUs,
Istio, and more.
Again, at the
bottom of this page,
once you've configured
all of your options,
you can Create the cluster
that you've configured,
you can Cancel, or you can get
the REST or gcloud CLI command
to create this cluster.
Now I'll choose to Create and
begin creation of this cluster.
The cluster will take
several minutes to create,
as Google Cloud is spinning
up the compute resources that
configure the cluster--
and configures the
cluster according
to your specifications.
You can see that the Autopilot
mode cluster is still
working on completing here.
Once it's done, it will be
indicated by a checkmark,
as you see here on
the existing clusters.
And you may also notice that
in an Autopilot mode cluster,
there are no number
of nodes indicated.
And for the one that's
creating, there's
no VCPU or memory
indicated because there
are no workloads running on it.
So when you do have a
workload running on it,
it will indicate how many VCPU
and memory are being used.
But you won't be able to
see the number of nodes,
because in Autopilot mode,
the nodes of your Kubernetes
cluster are not accessible
and you will not
be able to see them
in the console.
And as you can see from
the existing Standard Mode
cluster in this project,
when the Standard Mode
cluster finishes its creation,
you'll see the Number of nodes,
as well as the Total
amount of VCPU and memory
that are available to workloads
running on that cluster.
There's also a
notification here that
indicates that I'm not
running enough workloads to be
using this cluster efficiently.
So Autopilot Mode provides
a streamlined GKE cluster
creation process
with smart defaults,
applying Google's
recommended best
practices for high
availability and securing
hardening for your cluster.
The pay-per-workload model
of GKE Autopilot clusters
may also help increase
resource usage efficiency,
and thus optimize costs as
you pay only for the resources
you use.
The higher degree of management
provided by Autopilot mode
results in a cluster creation
process with fewer overall
configuration options--
the goal being to
get you to the stage
where you can run your
workloads on Kubernetes faster.
Standard mode clusters offer
more flexibility and control,
but also require you
to think more carefully
about the many
considerations that
can go into your GKE Standard
Mode cluster's configuration.
Whether Autopilot or
Standard Mode, GKE
aims to provide
you with the tools
you need to be successful
running your applications
on Kubernetes and Google Cloud.
With the concepts
discussed in this video,
we're confident
you'll be on your way
to building a GKE cluster
that suits your needs.
You can get started with GKE
by visiting the Google Cloud
Console, as we've
explored in this video,
and check out the links
below for additional guides
and resources.
And stay tuned for our next
videos, where we dive deeper
into GKE topics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]